c'est wayne et des coutumes et des
parfums c'est ouais c'est être avec nous
ça faisait
oui exactement dix ans mais les voir
faire disons que j'ai pas vu ça fait
disons que c'est pas vu je sais on a vu
les deux autres zigotos way stomie et
pacy ouais mais quoi je n'avais pas vu
j'aimerais que tu m'aimais plus t'es
dingue parce que c'est vrai qu'on va
prendre on était très potes tous les
deux oui franchement c'est vrai très
très potes et je peux vous dire on se
voyait à la bibliothèque
je te rappelle
c'est vrai beaucoup fait de lecture
ensemble ouais ouais on appris beaucoup
de choses sur la vie oui oui calme toi
quand même aller jouer avec nous bien
sûr talons bruno oui ça va être des
commencements célibataire comme toujours
c'est à dire complètement
oui j'ai pas du tout de béthanie c'est à
dire après tout petit ami lancement non
non je suis célibataire célibataire oui
[Rires]
célibataire est avec toi
pour l'instant aucune des costumes et
des parfums de ouais si tu arrives
à la prévision
[Applaudissements]
je laime coup à tous genres c'est ça
bruno non c'est géraldine en asie et
roxy manon il est intelligent mais le
voilà assez torturée quoi tend à dj ton
style oui c'est quand même fort allez on
va jouer tout de suite c'est le jeu de
table on regarde voilà je ne vois pas le
vôtre bah ouais et bientôt ça s'accélère
merci donc vous voulez répondre à faut
répondre du monde et je fais max evans
ou finir tout le ballon merci à wigan va
être enlevé le truc ah ouais j'suis une
barrette de barrett way offrir des
muscles baril et d'hélium
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me dois de l'argent et n'a jamais été
sur tf1
vous aimez un chiffre que vous avez fait
pour des missions michel c'est quand
même c'est quelqu'un qui sera difficile
en tout cas
éliminé du panel ouais un peu comme toi
il a quelque chose de particulier c'est
d'être à la base de l'histoire
télévisuelle vrai donc donc il est
indéboulonnable tu resterais sur france
télé pas sorti cet été sur france 2
c'est ma vie je viendrai chez toi c'est
bien payé
[Musique]
elle élève seule l'aide